foreign
a very important role because you mold
the future of your nation and water
Nation will become based on the kind of
grudges you produce I think this should
be a platform that every faculty
all over the world that wants to be at
the best and what they do should look at
it and adapt the content and have their
own innovative ideas to the content how
do you show them how the test of real
life is we do that by
the Laboratories either simulation
Laboratories a real life practical and
Laboratories difficult things to do but
is already done for you in ocw all you
have to do is just do some few
modification and there you are you have
it
we live as well you should have at least
a foundation in being able to design a
cheap
so we actually adopted the ocwr we
adopted it completely so at MIT you have
two or three instructors who are the
best in that field and then they have
support staffs like graduate assistants
graduate teaching assistants graduates
are the upgraders and all that so it's
like you have a whole team teaching the
course so the pace at MIT for that
course is very fast
so now bring it back here so you have
only me teaching the course
there's no way I'm going to match that
so at first when I brought in the
content from ocw it's kind of raised
some questions about some complaints
from the students because it's like
adding more activities or tasks to what
they do so it's like they feel like why
are you taking us through this stressful
part as at that time the current market
software Market in our country
was not the demand but not to rigorous
compared to now
yeah so but later they could say that
for that to be globally competitive they
need to have best practices a standard
and the master they can say that that
matters so
what we did was that we spreaded the
course into two semesters so that
reduced the pace and give more room to
do a lot of things the the goal of of
the of the causes to train students to
write
soft develop software that are free from
Bugs ready for a change and easy to
understand that's phrase alone
changes a lot of things when we start to
let you know classes and we know that is
our Focus it's changes a lot of things
about the past section the student about
preparation and about the goals and
objects of the students as well
now I want to follow the bloom taxonomy
M of teaching not just for a student to
understand no but how can we go up to
the create level before that's not what
we have it's just a bunch of materials
and Mathematics that will go to class
and just teach from there till the exam
they will crime what they know and act
them and pass so now I try to make it
different
so that's why I stress high quality
ocw materials can really not only the
students they can also help you as
educator to learn because it was a new
field for me too so I needed to actually
learn and it actually made learning
those things easier
engineer than going to the class and
participating seeing a real life problem
going to the lab experiencing the
problem sleeping on it and tomorrow go
to the class using Theory and solve the
problem it gives you more intuition of
being engineered just streaming YouTube
videos and taking some online courses
it doesn't get too near to the real life
thing apart from adding to your students
is going to really add two USF accounts
because you're going to be challenged by
the kind of content you see is going to
challenge you first to make sure you
master your field your own content your
own courses
uh if you have any challenge just reach
out to Etc fellows your University or in
your neighboring University they should
be able to help you because they have an
experience using this platform and the
other thing is also need to assess if if
the objective of that course aligns with
your own program because some courses
are designed with some objectives in
mind which is not necessarily yours or
you don't have all the objectives so you
need to know you need to be aware and
that's where ocw comes into play
exposing your students to ocw resources
will make them to be globally
competitive
this alignment of the course is left for
every lecturer to do it it's something
that have to take years of experience
and feedback for you to achieve so ocw
will be a great help and help you
achieve that so to me oer uh generally
is valuable in the sense that it gives
students access to the body of knowledge
in the field they are going to
specialize in essentially they are going
for research and also give them access
to the top experts in those fields so
they are aware of current thinking they
are aware of what the trends in that
field are going to be and they are
prepared for it so a lot of this is what
keeps us inspired in the teaching line
seeing that some of your students are
having a very good outcome it makes you
know that their future is promised